well let me tell you something about
corpses man they found 200 decaying
corpses improperly stored in a funeral
in Oklahoma brother the owners of the
place were charged with 200 counts of
abusing a corpse dude you can't abuse a
corpse brother not in the state of
Oklahoma dude Oklahoma cares about their
corpses brother they treat him with
respect dude they give him all
certificates to Starbucks brother and
they let him run for public office dude
and then they give him F fashion Awards
brother what the is going on here best
dressed corpse dude best corpse hat
brother best corpse Ensemble dude best
corpse Couture
brother best corpse collection dude best
corpse designer brother and that's
corpses dude